a rock Ryman I was born in the
Netherlands my father comes from a poor
laborer family he had to go to work when
he was 14 the self-made man became a
union leader my mother grew up in
Indonesia which was then a Dutch colony
and spent the years of the war in a
prison or a Japanese camp she survived
and I was her first born so I grew up
basically in a poor liberal Catholic
family in the Netherlands that's no
that's where I come from when I was
young I think it was definitely my
mother yes I mean she knew about life
right so I grew up in a family in which
you know there were some rules or some
ideas the first one was life in general
it's not funny
be aware of that secondly accept the
fact that you have to take
responsibilities free and when life is
not funny but when you accept your
responsibilities never give up don't
compromise do what you have to do so you
know with me if those things and then
for my parents who were uneducated that
the children could get an education
could go to university was their dream
was their dream so when I finally after
a very difficult high school period
which took me 8 years normally a 6 years
but it took me 8 years because I really
hated it and finally managed to go to
university I spent 10 years studying and
I still regret that there was only 10
years you know it could have been
endless it was just 10 years of reading
books books books books books books and
at my an old friend of mine once told me
that a reader in some ways I consider
myself a reader you
all they start with one book and then
you read back for me that book was the
magic mountain of Thomas month and so I
started to read everything of Thomas
Manor fruit Thomas mom it was channeled
to Schopenhauer Nietzsche go to you know
and you know trying to become familiar
with this whole world and it's this
whole whole mindset which now is known
as the world of European humanism and
the work I'm doing is basically trying
to to continue that tradition you know
trying to transmit the ideas of that
world but in the so called formative
years I think you know I was scratching
myself I would I become a secret agent
probably influenced by James Bond a
journalist you know investigating the
truth and then finally I I did something
which might look completely different
but it's not exactly the case I think I
started to study theology by training
I'm theologian which I studied for 10
years but even I'm not real theology
because my whole work was basically
focused on again you know Thomas Mann
and and and and and that and that whole
world but I do think a I grew up in this
family of six children without money so
my mother to deal with everything as she
learned me to read when I was free so I
essentially I have to feel me that the
only thing I can do and I could do all
my life is reading books so when I
realized okay sacré secret agent I I'm
missing some skills probably a
journalist then my father told to me he
said look he said you can always become
a journalist but start you know with a
huge background and then I became so
fascinated by that world that you know I
continued that study although you know
I'm not publishing the journal so I mean
the whole sense of communication is
still with